okay so venom let there be carnages out
digitally so i thought we'd take a look
over the film to talk about all the
easter eggs hidden details and
references to the comics that are in it
there's some brilliant callbacks in the
movie and lots of things that you missed
yes you which we're going to be covering
for the next 15 minutes or so full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't had a
chance to check it out then i highly
recommend that you check out now if you
enjoy the video then please drop a
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
to become my lobster wait wait eddie
what you doing
now without the way thanks for clicking
this now let's get into our venom let
there be carnage breakdown very very
poor intro now the post-credit scene of
the movie was a big talking point as it
finally brought venom into the mcu the
scene opens on a telenovela in which we
see two characters arguing about their
relationship which of course reflects
the themes of the movie eddie brings up
that the characters fell out because
they kept an insane secret from each
other which makes venom offer him a
chance to see a fraction of the 80
billion light years that his species has
experienced venom also mentions the hive
mind and in case you don't know he comes
from a species called the clinton they
worship a god called null who first
created them as one branching
consciousness nil had a weapon known as
the necro sword which potentially could
be the blade that was teased at the end
of the eternals in its post-credits
scene there's a possibility that they've
changed up the ebony blade to encompass
this but just in case they don't gor the
butcher also carried it and we know that
he'll be played by christian bale in the
upcoming thor love and thunder film
clinton also translates to cage and by
shifting universe venom is very much
breaking out of his just as he gives
eddie a small fraction of what they've
experienced the room warps around them
and it changes into its much brighter
mcu counterpart it's kind of funny how
the mcu is often brought up as being
light and colorful and we watches even
eddie's backpack changes to something
more pleasant looking now if you slow
down the footage you can actually catch
a split second where the daily bugle
logo appears on the tv and later in the
scene it transforms to show the news
report being delivered by jay jonah
jameson throughout the film we see his
eddie writes for the daily bugle and
this carries across the logo and font
from the raimi trilogy but for this
scene it's changed to the infowars-esque
style of reporting that was teased at
during the end of far from home
interestingly the daily bugle in this
movie is the west coast edition and
normally in the comics it's just located
in new york peter is shown unmasked in
his black and red spiderman costume and
this imagery somewhat pulls from the
civil war comic book run in which he
unmasked for the world and was plastered
all over news reports in the background
we can catch a sign that says pen one
which is actually the outside of
pennsylvania station this is where the
reveal happened at the end of far from
home and as always it's all connected
now he might even get unmasked during
the scene we can see happening at the
station in which people pile on him like
he's just said he knows when the third
trailer for no way home is dropping now
jay jonah calls him a spider menace
which is of course a play on him
constantly calling him a menace in the
comics he says that the world is caught
in his web of lies and double pod combo
here that even the punisher would be
proud of however web of lies is actually
the name of a spider-man animated series
episode starring j jonah jameson and
it's also potentially playing on the
name of the playstation game spider-man
web of shadows now we pick about the
saint estes reform school in 1996 to
meet a young cletus cassidy i really
respect that sony tried telling us that
woody harrelson was a teenager in the
90s and i just imagine this guy walking
around the home saying how do you do
fellow kids now this location is based
on the saint esther's home for boys
which is where cletus was sent to in the
comics as a kid like most serial killers
cletus originally started off by
torturing animals and he pushed his
grandmother down the stairs which of
course killed her in the comics cletus
electrocuted his mother and she snapped
on him and tried to smash his head in
like you should smash that like button
the backstory in the movies told an
animated form and i thought it was
really creative how they managed to
avoid the r writing by doing it this way
now in the comics his father caught his
mother trying to murder him and almost
beat her to death which led to him being
put in jail but many believe that it was
actually cleous who was behind the
attacks cletus burned down the orphanage
in the comics which too happens in the
movie and at the location we also meters
love francis barrison aka shriek in the
comics the pair teamed up during the
maximum carnage run and ended up going
on a rampage after escaping prison which
is sort of what we get in this movie
shriek also talks about her mutations in
the film possibly hinting towards the
x-men coming down the line the pair
communicate with a piece of string
through a wall and shriek actually holds
under this piece of string throughout
her life even having it as a ring in the
cell when she's an adult francis is
escorted out of the home by detective
mulligan who in the comics becomes
infected with a symbiote called toxin
which this movie may be hinting towards
in its final few scenes toxin comes from
carnage and in some ways he's very much
venom's grandson making for a really
messed up family as shriek is taken out
we can also see that the police fan has
the numbers 1412 scrawled all over it
this could be a reference to the marvel
comic runes of ravencroft carnage issue
1 1412 which dealt with both the villain
of this movie and the location that
shriek has taken to mulligan ends up
shooting her in the eye which creates a
score and this is an auteur eye markings
in the comics this becomes even more
prominent in the marriage scene later on
in which we can see the score getting a
black lining to it at one point
mulligan's office we can see a wanted
poster behind him that says e larsen
which is a note of the comic book writer
eric larson who not only founded image
comics but is also someone who wrote
spider-man and venom stories she's then
taken to ravencraft which is basically
arkham asylum in the marvel universe
we've already seen an alternate version
of this location as it appeared as a
laboratory in the amazing spider-man 2
and it's the place that housed electro
whilst he was experimented on here we
also meet dr pazzo a character from the
comic books that carnage took hostage
during the carnage unleashed storyline i
absolutely love the sound design in
these scenes and if you get a dolby
atmos setup you can really feel as the
bass rumbles through your entire house
as they put the earbuds in in fact fam
you know what the entire sound design is
really well put together on this film
and i think people don't appreciate this
kind of stuff enough but we love you
guys you do a great job now throughout
the movie we get the idea that carnage
is very much part of cletus's blood
whereas with eddie it warped over his
head if you slow down the
transformations you can see that carnage
very much comes out of cletus's cells
this idea is laced in scenes i get
pushing the lethal injection back up
through the tube and also how we can see
the symbiote moving through his veins
cletus is obsessed with blood and he
even writes eddie a postcard using his
blood as ink further tying to this idea
he also crushes a spider which could be
a little meta joke about spiderman and
carnage going head to head in the comics
cletus's cell is littered with wall
carvings including a giant tree that
venom later reminds eddie of when
they're investigating his crimes this
tree somewhat appears later on in the
movie and we can see that there's a
heart carved into it which also shows up
on the drawing on the tree is the line
today the strife was given between the
suffering this actually pulls from the
poem prometheus and this is of course a
character from greek mythology who stole
fire from the gods and gave it to the
mortals this is somewhat reflected in
cletus who steals the symbiote from
eddie and with this he can wield the
powers of a god in eddie's apartment
when he has an argument with venom the
big guy shoves him into the ceiling
which causes a hole in it and if you
look about the apartment you'll also see
other holes started about showing that
this has happened before eddie says that
they have to be responsible and venom
says that responsibility is for the
mediocre poking fun at spider-man saying
with great power comes great
responsibility we learned that eddie
gave him two chickens to eat but he
ended up making them his pets and the
symbiote calls them sunny and cher sonny
and share were very much a power couple
at one point due to their string of hits
however they had a very messy breakup
with sunny taking most of the money
they'd made in later years the pair
ended up reconciling and cher even read
the eulogy at his funeral this naming of
the chickens i think is very much put in
place to reflect the split that venom
and eddie go through in the movie before
they learn to put their differences to
the side venom also plays let's call the
whole thing off at one point which is
from the musical shall we dance this
song's about a couple disagreeing about
minuscule things like calling a potato a
tomato or something and basically they
called the whole thing off i know it's
not that yeah before you start
commenting now this is of course
foreshadowing the divide between the
pair coming to boiling point shortly
after this scene i don't know if this is
a reach but the movie actually follows
the superhero sequel trope in which the
main character loses their powers for a
bit before getting them back this
happened in superman 2 spider-man 2 and
deadpool 2 and venom 2 is basically
following the same sort of plotline now
unfortunately due to stanley's death
they've not been able to have the
classic cameos that were in almost all
of the marvel movies over the last 20
years however the creators behind these
projects have got pretty sophisticated
in how they've laced him throughout
things this includes having his birthday
on a license plate in one division and
also having him appear in a wall
painting during loki venom like there'll
be carnage has a great one too and when
eddie enters mrs chens we can see that
he pushes a magazine on a stand back
that has stan's face on it what's this
stan lee hey hello
now stan of course coming out at the end
of the previous venom movie so it's
great to see him back in this film and a
huge excelsior to him wherever he is now
eddie meets back up with anne and you
might recognize this restaurant from the
first movie as it was the place they had
dinner together now shout outs eric boss
from new rock stars are pointing out
that in the background we can catch a
red light whereas in the original it was
navy blue at the beginning of the movie
the ravencroft gods also put earbuds in
which blink blue and we can catch a red
light shining on their face further
calling back to this imagery this use of
red against blue very much hints at
carnage coming for venom and it's not
too long before cletus bites him and
takes part of the symbiote this scene is
a bit different to what happens in the
comics and though eddie mackley is in a
prison they did change things up quite a
lot eddie was actually clear as his
cellmate and then when he escaped prison
some of the symbiote got on him here
however they have this interaction and
then cletus bursts out of his execution
and goes on a rampage during this scene
cletus says something wicked this way
comes which could be a nod to macbeth in
which the witches said it when
discussing the titular character however
it was also the title of the ray
bradbury book something wicked this way
comes this was about an evil being that
seemed to grant everyone their hearts
desires but instead all it did was suck
the life out of them just like a
parasite this is somewhat like the
relationship that carnage has with
cletus as it frees him reunites him with
his lost love and lets them go on a
rampage but it's clear it's after its
own things now shout out to ryanairy for
pointing that out and for also it's
saying that just before eddie meets
cletus a venom says he wants to eat a
prisoner eddie brings him making a
murderer which was a netflix documentary
that tried to argue that convicted
killer steven avery was actually
innocent the rules are that they can
only eat bad guys so eddie doesn't want
to risk one of the people being in jail
for the wrong reasons cletus also brings
up that they are kindred spirits as the
pair both feel responsible for their
mother's deaths and they both had
abusive fathers however going beyond
that they both lost the woman that they
love and in the movie both have to deal
with a new partner coming into their
lives through the form of a symbiote
cletus says eddie is going on a magical
misery tour which is a play on the
beatles album the magical mystery tour
this was a psychedelic journey with a
brightly coloured rainbow cover which
may or may not be giving a nod to the
coming out party venom has later on hey
they don't call me rich richards for no
reason you're punk now from this point
cletus escapes sticks his tongue down a
dude's throat which i've heard happens a
lot in prison and he goes on a married
jig cletus is now out of san quentin and
he actually changes some of the words
from johnny cash's song san quentin
which had the following lyrics and i'll
walk out a wiser weaker man mr
congressman you can't understand however
cletus changes it up to and i'll walk
out a wiser stronger man mr warden you
taste just like ham carnage hacks the
internet itself which it's a bit weird
in it but this is actually a nod of the
comics in which he snuck into people's
computers and waited until they'd
returned home serial killers like btk
often used to cut phone lines and wait
in people's closets until they came home
raz carnage has somewhat changed this up
so he's now traveling into their houses
through the internet in order to lie low
carnage breaks shriek free and mrs chen
becomes anti-venom i said antique venom
hey now venom also has a coming out
party in which he's finally breaking
free of eddie here we meet the rapper
little sims who actually had a song
called venom which went viral earlier
this year also when venom grabbed the
mic did anyone else hope that someone
would just shout do a rap or was it just
me go on venom do it do a wrap now eddie
is arrested and then anne breaks him out
using venom which makes her turn into
the she-venom form like how she was in
the first film after she's captured all
of the characters come together at
church slash cathedral which is also
where the maximum carnage game had its
final level at in the comics churches
are very important as it's typically
where venom was created at eddie brock
went there in spider-man 3 to pray to
god that he kills all the other movie
youtubers sorry peter parker and it's
definitely laced in with his origin
story there's lots of religious imagery
in the scene and even the title let
there be carnage is actually a play on
the phrase let there be light which
comes from the bible the blood of christ
idea could tie back to the blood of
eddie creating a higher power within
cletus and it brings this religious
imagery altogether carnage also goes
into a crucifixion pose at one point and
circus say that this is meant to be a
nod to leonardo's vitruvian man leonardo
created this in order to show that there
was some intelligent design to humans
due to the ratios within the body all
fitting together perfectly it's clear
carnage views himself as a god and i
love how this motif is carried
throughout the film during this scene
eddie is wearing a detroit's lines
jacket over a mumford t-shirt which is
actually a nod to eddie murphy who wore
the same thing in beverly hills cop i
wanted to see if there was something
deeper than that but both tom hardy and
andy circus said it was literally just
because the character was called eddie
see so sometimes they're just not that
deep i keep telling you that now the
battle escalates with carnage turning on
shriek which juxtaposes how eddie and
venom both care for anne there's a
falling scene and this could be a nod to
the death of gwen stacy which is framed
in a similar light within the church
this motif is shown with and falling in
the reflection of venom's eyes which was
not only used in the amazing spider-man
2 but it also popped up in the first
spider-man movie when green goblin
dropped mj it also seems like it's
getting referenced in spider-man no way
home as mj falls off the statue of
liberty at one point and peter has to
dive after her to save her gwen died and
now venom saves anne shriek somewhat
suffers the same fate as her carnage and
cletus just aren't a good match and this
is a no to the warren ellis story mind
bomb in which this revelation was
discussed quite a lot venom bites clears
his head off and then decides to head
off which is when he starts to embrace
the lethal protector role the lethal
protector storyline actually involved
venom teaming up with spider-man in
order to become somewhat of an anti-hero
it was his first ever limited series and
i'm putting money on it right now that
it'll be the tagline of venom three
eddie quotes don quixote and says the
mantra facts are the enemy of truth
which very much symbolizes this ending
as though eddie has stopped carnage he's
now seen as an outlaw the fact is that
eddie saved the city and stopped a
criminal rampage but all that people
will see is that he's a dangerous alien
and they'll no doubt hunt him as well
the pair end up on a beach together with
venom's toes in the sand calling back to
venom's stream of doing this earlier in
the movie we can hear a cover of the
song love will tear us apart in the
background and it very much hints
towards our relationship being a rocky
one in the future though they are on the
run they won't be for much longer as the
pair are transported to the mcu in the
post-credits scene which closes out the
movie and that's all the easter eggs
hidden details and secret meanings that
we found in the film obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts if there's any we
missed then make sure you comment below
and let me know we are running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of zack snyder's dc trilogy
on the 30th of november and all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now say that to
you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of all the tv spots for
spider-man noway home which will be
linked on screen right now there's some
amazing easter eggs in it so definitely
go watch it right after this without the
way thank you for sitting through the
video i've been poor i'll see you in the
next one take care peace